you did a the Johnny Cash show and
um
that was cool and I would imagine uh
that I mean there's a guy that's a very
different situation where you're
being invited on this massive American
Stars TV show but also he's someone who
you would really respect yeah yeah no I
I really like Johnny Cash was he nice to
you was there you know hardly even got
to speak to him really but uh that's
okay he was busy yeah he was it was the
Johnny Cash show yeah you got to realize
in our eyes doing this I'm what 23 years
old right I'm I'm going on a television
show I was petrified yeah so I was kind
of thinking about the song I was going
to sing and was I going to screw it up
or not
that's all I thought about yeah so I
really don't remember much else about it
right uh well it's funny because one of
the songs that you
picked
is a Johnny Cash song Oh yeah and
um again this is a ballad of a Teenage
Queen what did this song mean to you
when does this enter your radar
oh right in the 50s there about the same
time as I was talking was I was talking
about the the Wayward Wind and the other
song Four Strong Winds uh Four Strong
Winds was after the Wayward wind was
sooner and this song was sooner than the
Wayward win these are back farther in my
life
I've been in maybe grade two grade three
kind of and this is what I was thinking
about is that you are a Storyteller you
like you I I think uh better than just
about anybody you tell a great story
when you're uh in your songs and this is
the classic story song this is Johnny
Cash telling us the tale of uh the
teenage beauty queen so let's give it a
listen see where it takes you Ballad of
a Teenage Queen by the great Johnny Cash
what do you think just hold up hold up
for you oh yeah yeah definitely man I I
gotta I mean that's there's a couple
things I need to say about that song I
love that song it's so great
um
when has that happened that a woman's
left town made it big in Hollywood and
then said I'm gonna give up all my money
and go back to the boy who works at the
candy store dream on
show me one example of that happening in
history and I'll back off
uh yeah I just uh I had heard that song
before but when you mentioned it I went
back and was listening to it and
those bad I don't know we don't know who
that's doing the backup vocals I don't
know if it sounds like it could it could
it be the Jordan airs or is it just I
think it's the uh I think it's the I
well I always thought it was the
Tennessee too yeah they sound good yeah
they do sound good but there might have
been Someone Else singing with them too
he's had the girl singing the high voice
going through the whole thing yeah
um yeah that's but that's such a I mean
that sounded like the record that I was
remembering when I wrote it down right
that that's what the sound is and the
other two songs
sounded kind of like that and that one
was an original I think right close
anyway same Vibe I feel like it would be
a blessing and a curse to have your ear
because
I don't pick that stuff apart
necessarily
but you hear it and if it's
in Stereo if it's been remixed you're
like I'm out
well I'm different I'm going when they
did that what else did they do things
are different they got more room for the
base and more thread spread things
around so it's not for me it's the it's
the feeling of the mix the feeling of
the song the more immediate it was the
closer to the original one yeah and then
you feel the song and the essence of it
and then as things get modified and
changed you you get farther away from
that so that's that's all I'm missing
it's not so much the mixer one thing or
another but it's the essence of the song
that comes from the original yeah
it's funny when I hear songs from that
period of my life that are evocative to
me uh and actually some of them yours
it's like I I go right to usually
hearing it through
um you know our Pontiac station wagon oh
yeah uh you know system analog radio
that's how I heard 99 of our music we
weren't allowed to mess with my dad's
record player because he had like a nice
record player so I mean we could some
but mostly I'm hearing stuff
on the radio and that was how I
experienced everything and so I
associate a lot of these songs now with
being in a car and moving yeah and it's
it's interesting how that have
affects how you then later on hear the
song yeah it it because when it's way
back there in your life and you have
this memory it's Vivid
and uh who knows what you do with it in
all those years
you may have enhanced it you may have it
may be exactly the way it was or it may
maybe uh you know it just may be
different in some way because when you
have a thought for so long and you
remember a memory it becomes more than
just that over time so that's why when
you go back sometimes it's not like you
thought it was going to be right
I um
is that great no I was listening did I
scare you with my glasses no there I
don't know that's good it's a bold
statement my glasses yeah it is it's
kind of a Clark can you see through
those absolutely not I didn't think so
you're gone now you're just uh you're a
Smee you're a smear I see a smear and a
floating hat radios saved us again
there's there's a big business for radio
in the future and trust me it's not lost
on me that uh people are very happy that
I got off TV and into radio really it
was happening I know it is happening but
also there's an implied insult there
which is it's so nice to hear you and
not see your Goddamn face it's the
future radio's the future that's where
we're gonna hear uh uh what music is
yeah
because you can broadcast
what people love about vinyl over the
radio and this and the transmitters are
still in the top of all the old
buildings around different towns so a
new radio station could come along and
broadcast in analog so everybody got
vinyl quality
all you need is the right radio to pick
it up with which is
a fortune-making thing that any
investment wants to get right into
so be great if you busted out your
product right now you started Hawking it
yeah the analog radio